الداخل والخارج ايضا مهددا بسبب ايران
والمسيرات احدى الوسائل التي تهدد بها
ايران استقرار المنطقه خطرا انتقل لمناطق
عده ومختلفه ووصلت الى اوكرانيا لكن
النشاط العسكري الايراني لا يقتصر في
الجوار الاوروبي على دعم موسكو في الحرب
منطقه البلقان السوق مزدهره جديده
للمسيرات الايرانيه وبحسب مؤسسه جيمس
ساوند تعمل طهران على تعطيل البيئه
الامنيه في المنطقه من خلال هجمات
الالكترونيه ضد بعض حلفاء الناتو
الاقليميين مثل الحجامات ضد المانيا
واخرها كانت في سبتمبر الماضي
بالتوازي تعملوا ايران على تطوير علاقتها
بدول مثل صربيا والمسيرات هي الوسيله وزير
الخارجيه الايراني
العام الماضي اللي يناقش شراء بلغراد
مسيرات ايرانيه وقبلها بشهرين جاء اكيد من
مستشار المرشد يحيى رحيم صفوي اثنتان 22
دوله قدمت طلبات لشراء مسيرات من ايران
ومن بينها صربيا وارمينيا ورغم نفي وزاره
الدفاع الصربيا هذه الانباء وتاكيد انها
تخطط وتنتج وتطور المسيرات لكن مجله فورس
سلطت الضوء على ان هناك اسبابا قد تجعل
صربيا تتمم الصفقه وعلى راسها السعر
المنخفض للمسيرات الايرانيه عشرون الف
دولار للمسيره الواحده ان تمت الصفقه
ستكون صربيا اكبر مشغلا للطائرات المسيره
في البلقاء هو
سلوكازيا الايراني بحسب وصفي مؤسسه جيمس
تاون شغل الغرب بالحرب الاوكرانيه تاركينا
البلقان على شفا حرب جديد والوصف هنا يبقى
كالتي السوشيه
تحاول ايران استغلال هذه التوترات مثلا
بين صربيا وكوسوفو وتوترات زادت بين
البلدين نهايه العام الماضي جعلك سوبو
تطلب زياده انتشار النت على اراضيها اكثر
من العدد الحالي
3800 جندي وايضا استغلال التوتر بين
ارمينيا واذربيجان وزير الخارجيه الايراني
اكتوبر الماضي وبحث مساله المسيرات لكن ده
ارمينيا هدفه اخر من التزود بالمسيرات
الايرانيه وهو معادلتهم ميزان القوه مع
المصريات التركيه التي ساعدتها انقر
اذربيجان
في حرب 2020
بالوكاله تريدها ايران الجنوب القوقاز على
غرار ما تقوم به في الشرق الاوسط لكن هناك
اسيا الوسطى ايضا طيران اقامه العام
الماضي في طاجكستان اول مصنع خارج ارضيها
لكن هناك هدف اخر جديد للمسيرات في
منطقتنا اعتدنا على تهديد طيران للممرات
المائيه القائمه هذه المره قد يضاف اليها
قناه السويس وذلك بحسب صحيفه جرس
الاسرائيليه ومن اجل ذلك تعمل طيران على
تسريع وزيادتي انتاج المسيرات واستخدام
الذكاء الاصطناعي فيها والهدف ذكره قائد
الحرس الثوري حسين سلامي
ماما كونان